sin votación en el congreso ni acuerdo
entre los demócratas pese a los
esfuerzos del presidente estadounidense
joe biden se trasladó hasta el capitolio
para negociar con los miembros de su
partido prometiendo que sus reformas
económicas y sociales serán aprobadas
por la cámara de representantes
hacen mil preguntas diferentes y todas
son legítimas te digo que lo vamos a
lograr
no importa cuando no importa si en 6
minutos 6 días o 6 semanas vamos a
conseguirlo
la visita de biden para presionar sobre
el estancado proyecto de ley de
infraestructura responde a las
divisiones internas que sufren los
demócratas el ala progresista se niega a
votar sobre las infraestructuras hasta
que el congreso apruebe un proyecto de
ley de bienestar social y cambio
climático de unos 3,5 billones de
dólares en contraparte los moderados
quieren reducir el tamaño de la
financiación del paquete el mandatario
reconoció que los demócratas no tienen
los votos suficientes para apoyar ambos
proyectos aunque creo que hay muchos
demócratas frustrados ahora mismo por el
hecho de que yo wyden haya esperado
tanto tiempo para involucrarse
se puede herir pero no hiere de muerte a
la presidencia de bailén hay una serie
de actores aquí creo que incluso la
credibilidad de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes pelosi se
tambalea en cuanto a ser la negociadora
hábil e intocable como lo demuestra el
hecho de que hayan tenido que posponer
la votación sobre infraestructuras que
se empeñó en convocar
con una estrecha mayoría en la cámara
del partido de baile no puede permitirse
perder demasiados votos en la
legislación sobre infraestructuras y es
poco probable que los republicanos del
congreso ayuden a aprobar los deseosos
de negar a byd en una victoria política
de cara a los comicios de medio término